tomorrow is the 15th anniversary of
reggie miller's final nba game
home loss to the pistons that eliminated
the pacers game
six second round reg had 27 points 11 of
16 from the floor
and a nine point defeat i text reggie
last night before the episode
and i just said good luck and then he
said tough crowd i said it's a crowd of
one
it's mj you survived reg you survived
were you nervous i was
i i was nervous for the simple fact of
that opening scene because they opened
it
with the fight right uh in 93.
so that could have gone a number of
different ways
but i think it kind of drew people in
and captivated people a little bit
but you're right it it was an audience
of one
this was mj's doc
[Music]
but i think it kind of pulled back the
veil
of how things were in the 90s
and how competitive not only he was but
a lot of the guys that he butt heads
with me being one of those guys so it
was it was cool to see
a little cathartic as you mentioned um
but it left me
shaking my head as well
i wanted to come on here and first say
i hate steve kerr i hate steve kerr
i hate him i love him when i work
it just painful memories
that game seven is just it just makes me
shake my head
why do you hate curse so much
because we expected mj
we expected scotty we didn't expect
little stevie those 11 points
were the difference makers and it was
impactful
11 points in game seven big
big shots against us
how does rick schmitz lose that tip
he's 7-4 reg
i can't answer that okay all right can i
answer that
um it doesn't guarantee that we would
win that ball game
but i liked our chances jordan was very
complimentary though
i you know that the pacer team i mean he
he knew that that was that was a battle
that was as good a battle as he was
probably ever in
in those uh in the 90s and people need
to understand too
when they won 72 games 72 and 10
two of those ten losses came against us
and we
really weren't on you know a contending
team at that time
you know the year before um we played a
physical style
of basketball led by larry brown
which was then kind of taken over by
larry bird and rick carlisle
um but we had tough tough dudes and my
davis brothers
rick you know we added you know sam
perkins we had lasalle thompson we had
sam mitchell so we had a lot of guys
that understood the game had been around
a long time
and you know i i said this in in the doc
last night
you know we we really didn't fear them
we respected them obviously you respect
all your opponents
but it was kind of comical at times
watching how other teams
approached the bulls and how we
approached them um
but it was fun it was it was fun
do you have any different memory like do
you take away anything different
from michael and the bulls having been
in it
and you're so close to it but now you're
watching it as a
quote-unquote fan anything different
think about this as much as
michael has achieved how iconic
he is right six nba championships
you know twice three time back to back
to back
champions you could see and only a real
athlete and a competitor could see this
remember last week when i told you i
always remember
the bad games versus all the great
moments that i've had
you remember you could see when he's
talking about
a chase for number seven and when
they're talking about how maddening is
him walking away at the height of his
his powers you can see how much that
pains him
this is a guy that has achieved
everything he has
six six rings
but what what is clawing at him is the
what if
what if on that seventh and then
breaking up the team
and it kind of pains me to see that a
little bit because we all
hey we were all shuffling to get in line
to come after them i had my shot in 98
who would have been the next year
you know so it pains me to see that
that look on his face him not having
that opportunity
hey until they beat us why break it up
i was also and people want to know you
know would they what would they have
done those two years if michael didn't
play baseball and
i don't know if they would have won the
title to be fair to houston i don't know
if they would have won the title because
i do think that there was some burnout
there with michael
and i think you saw burnout there at the
end of 98 reg where
we we can't imagine what that must be
like
to live in that world and he created
this world
sure like he was he was held captive by
being
air jordan and i think it took its toll
and people don't understand 82 game
regular season and
back in the 90s there was no load
management
right yeah we played we had to play and
michael
was one of those guys who understood
there is going to be someone
in this building who hasn't seen me for
the first time who played a lot of money
to come see me play
so he was going to lace him up so think
about this he played 80 to 82 games
eight nine years straight then a
grueling taxing
playoff schedule where he won six
championships
you're right fatigue was starting to set
in and i think
teams were getting better as well um you
know
we'll never know with the whole houston
and their two championships
i would have loved to see it because
just as much as
we didn't have an answer for mj as
guards
no one had an answer for our team elijah
one in the middle as well
so that would have been a fabulous
matchup we're talking to reggie miller
hall of famer turner sports
nba analyst you see yourself
in this fight with michael jordan like
are you are your kids watching this
we put the kids to bed oh okay i made
sure we put the kids to bed because i
don't know what mj was going to say i
told you i didn't know
um i knew the fight was probably going
to be a part of it i didn't know it was
going to lead the show
but it kind of set up the night and it
set up
what was the anticipation of that epic
seven game series
with chicago um but
people need to understand that i just
didn't go
and shove michael jordan i'm not that
stupid i hope they saw the preceding
plays
because he was elbowing me a couple
times and again
like i said i can't hold my tongue and
i'm not going to back down
so it led to what it but it just shows
you the power
of mj how do i get thrown out we both
were fighting so how do i get thrown out
in my own building and that's what
makes that's what burns me and then he
goes on to score 40 and they win
like that doesn't make sense it doesn't
do you believe the pizza story that now
it's food point why
why did it change from flu to food
poisoning and it changed
for the documentary well how are you
going to say food poisoning
food poisoning doesn't sound right flu
game because
it kind of looked like he had the flu
but the more
you think about it in the food poisoning
that it sounds about right so
what maybe pizzagate sounds good how
about pizzagate
hashtag no games it sounds flue game
sounded good right
you can't have five guys deliver a pizza
now i
that i don't believe i don't think five
yet first of all
michael jordan is not ordering those
other two guys as you know
glover the trainer and whoever his other
friend charlie or whatever that guy was
they're ordering the pizza under their
names how are they going to know is for
mj
don't you get your pizza from the lobby
you get it from the lobby they don't
like yeah you would you would go down to
the lobby and get the pizza you wouldn't
allow
first of all it's michael jordan and as
you saw he had pianos in his rooms on
the road
so obviously he was on a secure floor
and obviously he traveled with
about 30 security guards as we see in
this docu series
so why would he let them up on the floor
there's a lot of holes in here mj a lot
of holes in here
[Laughter]
it it it was interesting um when you
start to look at
when michael looked like he was going to
break down in this documentary
and then he would he would not he
couldn't allow himself to break down
like i can't it's a weakness i can't
allow when he says let's take a break
there
he was talking about how i don't i don't
think he could be any different than
what he was
i think he was this is who he is and he
was trapped in this
he could never turn this off reg ever
ever
and why apologize for it right
and he said this himself winning comes
at a price
did he push his players yes will purdue
was he an [ __ ]
yes okay right that's just how he was
and to me there's no reason to apologize
because he put a lot of money
in ryan's door's pocket in his teammates
pockets
in absolutely the league david stern
said it right
we were in you know 70 to 80 countries
and it expanded to close to 300
and a lot of that has to do with chicago
and the marquee name michael jordan
do you think it and if i think this was
a you know brilliant marketing plan by
michael jordan and his team to put this
out now
because of lebron and you know lebron
going to the lakers and maybe winning
another title and now all of a sudden
he's got four now all of a sudden got a
little bit more of a conversation here
i got a chance to sell some shoes i got
i can remind
of you know the people who saw me and i
can you know introduce myself to a new
generation here
i i think this was a brilliant marketing
plan
but is there is it all positive like
people take away positives from this reg
do you think or is there something
that's negative
about this that michael jordan might
regret
i i think the and i wouldn't necessarily
call it negative
but it did kind of raise eyebrows the
whole not
backing of the u.s senator in north
carolina
back in the day maybe not doing that to
me
that's what kind of separates mj
from lebron because lebron has the
platform and the tools
and this social backing to do that
mj was never about that
to me and you're right it checks all the
boxes for mj
he opened up a new audience he contin
air jordans continue to be
an iconic brand
so those are great things to me
i will go to my grave saying this i will
think
that mj is the goat
um but i think it put it to bed but let
me just say this okay
lebron's defense though i i think
lebron because of social media
and he's not afraid to speak his mind
i i think people view him in a different
light than mj because
he has those platforms mj would never
he would never do that i mean lebron has
started schools
to help kids out i don't think mj would
ever have done that
mj was all about the craft and winning
and i'm not saying lebron isn't
but in today's age of social media
you've got to have a package and lebron
has
to me a bigger portfolio and package
than mj but mj didn't have this in the
night in the 80s and 90s there was no
social media there was no twitter
instagram who would you rather play with
jordan or lebron and
my type of skills in my game yeah lebron
but if you're asking me who the better
player is
and who the best no better chance to win
it would be mj okay to win
because it was when it all cost
my skill set is playing with lebron
like i could play with magic probably
better than i probably could play with
mj
mj and i would butt heads we're just too
much alike
yeah i i was mentioning this that you
had larry and magic
or it was magic and larry and then all
of a sudden mike came along
and it's it's not like he stayed too
long with
magic and larry on their level he took
it to another
like he didn't they didn't give him the
bent on he took
the baton but was there any resentment
do you think with
the older guard in the nba with jordan
that
who are you coming in and you got your
own shoe
i mean this is this stuff really was i
know that clyde fraser had his own shoe
like some guys had their own shoe but
this this guy came out of nowhere from
the standpoint of
team isn't any good and here he comes
and now all of a sudden
there he goes and i think this kind of
goes to what
the whole beef maybe was with isaiah
there was grumblings again about
that first all-star game with isaiah
kind of freezing him out
in that all-star game um again i wasn't
there i wasn't on that all-star team but
you know
there's whispers about that and too much
too soon
but i kind of think he kind of proved
that he deserved all this
uh in terms of mj but in terms of magic
and larry because they rescued the nba
in the 80s right
and michael just took it to a different
level and he helped put money in the
in our pockets the rest of the players
because revenue sharing
tv rights that all expanded
because of mj and the success of chicago
coolest piece of memorabilia you got in
the crib
and again this is a rental this is not
all that
okay all right so this is a rental so we
don't have a lot of stuff here we're
just
laying our heads down here what would be
the coolest
thing remember i will show you the
coolest thing
just wait one second right there
this is the coolest thing damn patrick
reggie miller joining us on the dan
patrick show is he gonna bring in a
child
that's why
reggie going into another room here yeah
cause
he of course was affected by the fires
and they
had to get a uh a different house to go
to i was in los angeles at that time
when i saw reg when i was out there i
think i was doing uh
the uh interview show undeniable here
com
oh okay
[Laughter]
that's uh what exactly is that's your
that's a
almost a life size that's a that's right
right here
how big is that bobble head that that's
like mugsy bogues
i don't know who sent this to me how i
got it
it was one of my last years in indiana
how about you stand behind the bobble
head and we can't see you
but you move the head a little bit and
you just talk hey
reggie
do you really think do you really think
michael jordan's overrated reggie
yes i
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
the light skin assassin hey pop your
head up real quick i want to ask you
about the
i haven't heard anything from the
commissioner and
i'm assuming that's a good thing uh what
what do you think
uh what are we looking at here with the
nba the longer it goes
it's not gonna happen i think i know
they're opening practice facilities
i just don't see it dan i really don't
i hope i'm wrong it's a no-show i hope
me and my light-skinned bobble head can
go back to work but i just do not see it
when you brought it out i thought it was
austin crozier
[Laughter]
how about this look at the parts that
that was your rookie year where you had
that yes come on
mommy brown girl you know
well i'm glad you got your due last
night i didn't want mj to uh
say some things like he did some of
these other players but
again i did my interview in january or
february
so i don't think uh
they you know he he did his interviews
way earlier
december in my interview so if i would
have done my my interviews
a year ago remember this was two and a
half years in the making
this docu-series yeah so a lot of those
interviews with gary payton and
all those other guys they were probably
done early and that's why he had a
chance
to have a rebuttal he didn't have a
chance to have a rebuttal
carl malone didn't want to be
interviewed iron russell
refused i can see that stock stockton
begrudgingly
wasn't going to end well for those two
no it wasn't
ah thank you reg and little reg there uh
we appreciate it as always thank you bud
i appreciate it theodore you are truly
the best
my dad this is why we
are family that's reggie miller
and little reggie light skinned reg